aliens was directed by James Cameron and
once again star Sigourney Weaver as
Ripley and this time around she's been
in cryo sleep for quite some time and
when she awakens she realizes that her
entire life is basically gone and as I'm
sure most of you know she's immediately
sent back into the shit as an advisor
with a bunch of other soldiers because
the colonists on lv-426 which was the
place that had the derelict alien
spacecraft are no longer communicating
with anyone on the outside and if he
thought one was bad this time there's
quite a bit more James Cameron did
something with this movie really really
well I mean there's a lot of things he
absolutely nailed but one thing in
particular was not recreating the
success of Ridley Scott's alien
he made his own movie here where Ridley
Scott's movie was a masterclass in
science fiction suspense James Cameron's
version is a masterclass and science
fiction action this movie is fucking
awesome if one was bad for a crew of
people that weren't prepared what would
happen if a whole bunch went up against
some well-trained soldiers well they
still have acidic blood so everyone's
kind of fucked
I adore aliens this is one of the best
action movies ever made and a lot of it
doesn't even have to do with the aliens
this movie has such a great focus on
character in particular Ripley
Sigourney Weaver got nominated for Best
Actress in this movie just let that sink
in for a minute an actress in a big
summer popcorn movie with aliens and a
lot of explosions got nominated for Best
Actress at the Oscars that's
unprecedented that like never happens
but it is well deserved she is fantastic
and this movie's such a great
performance Ripley is still to this day
one of my favorite movie heroes and the
way I view it is Darth Vader was kind of
cool in Episode four and awesome but it
wasn't really until Empire Strikes Back
where you were like holy shit Darth
Vader is like the badass Ripley was
awesome an alien and I like Sigourney
Weaver a lot but in this movie so much
humanity is given to this character and
she's just so strong and her personality
is so well fleshed out in the script in
particular her relationship with Newt a
young girl that they find hiding out on
the
planet and if you've seen this special
edition which by the way we're going to
get into some spoilers here if you
haven't seen aliens what are you doing
just just what are you doing you're not
doing it right whatever you're doing is
you're not doing it right go to the
aliens now please in this special
edition there's an early scene with
Ripley where you learn that she has had
a daughter and that her daughter has
passed away while she was in cryo sleep
so it's this really awful moment for her
character and when she meets Newt their
relationship is given so much more
weight because you recognize that she
was a mother and she never got to say
goodbye to her daughter and her daughter
never found out what happened to her mom
so here's this young girl who needs help
and it really fleshes out both of those
characters so much more all that being
said I actually prefer the theatrical in
the long run the one addition that I
like is the idea that Ripley was a
mother that's the one addition I think
actually helps when compared from the
special edition to the theatrical beyond
that it's kind of a lot of padded scenes
that just lengthen the run time and ruin
the pacing so in the long run I prefer
watching the theatrical while having the
knowledge that Ripley had a daughter
once and that's just kind of how my
brain works but I have to talk about the
entire team this is such a fun team of
guys and girls because they have this
great camaraderie amongst them and if
you look into the making of this movie
you'll learn that James Cameron waited
until the end of the shoot to film a lot
of the scenes where the soldiers are
joking with one another so they could
have more of a brotherly sisterly type
feel with each other and that was
something I thought was really smart and
it shows in this movie quite a bit we've
built Axton which by the way I just got
to say it really sucks that the year I
decided to do my alien reviews is a year
we lose John Hurt and Bill Paxton rest
in peace to both of these actors huge
loss Bill Paxton this movie is so great
I mean he's got so many amazing lines of
course game over man game over very
pretty Bishop but what are we looking
for that's it
emergency venting that doesn't belong
hey Vasquez you ever been mistaken for a
man
no have you I mean there's just assholes
and elbows
man it's unending it's just a constant
unending stream of Awesomeness
get away from her you bitch we're aliens
could have done a lot of really stupid
things to expand upon the alien universe
and you know world build which is
apparently what every screenwriter today
is now trying to do this movie just said
no let's just take a group of people and
put them on an isolated place but we're
not going to make it a suspense film
there's going to be suspense but it's
not going to be the main focus we're
going to give them some weaponry but
we're going to make this an action movie
and we're going to build up the
character of Ripley and we're going to
flesh her character out and my god this
movie succeeded on every level I have
watched this movie at least once or
twice a year ever since I saw for the
first time as a teenager I adore aliens
the whole finale is just so
white-knuckle with the Queen it is some
of the best action suspense filmmaking I
have ever seen and it still holds up
today I'm going to give a lien a very
well-deserved A+ since I gave the same
grade to alien I'm sure you are
wondering which one I like more I like
alien just a tad more the first one is
just like a because alien is just
perfect it's perfect and it's original
and there is nothing wrong with it
aliens is amazing and I adore it but for
me alien is just it's almost it's
basically a perfect movie there's
nothing wrong with aliens I don't know
guys look forward to my review of alien
3 I'm going to be doing that with my
buddy Matt Brando we have done a lot of
research to make the best review of
alien 3 that we can because we have
differing viewpoints of it we're going
to watch both cuts and really examine
what David Fincher was trying to do and
just present a very respectful debate
but have some fun doing it the same
time I look forward to that guys you are
the best thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck my knife
[Music]